우리의 최고 성능 클래식 슈퍼컴퓨터는 점점 더 강력해지고 있고,
우리는 시스템 시뮬레이션을 포함한 계산 능력이 점점 향상되고 있어.
그런데 자연을 시뮬레이션하는 건 일반적으로 정말 어려운 문제야.
제 이름은 Victoria Lipinska이고, 오늘은 양자 컴퓨터에서
자연 시뮬레이션을 가능하게 할 수 있는 알고리즘 중 하나를 살펴볼 거야.
예시로 시작해서 카페인을 생각해 보자.
이건 단순한 분자야.
카페인 분자 하나의 에너지 구성을 표현하려면,
대략 10의 48제곱 비트가 필요해.
그건 10 뒤에 0이 48개 붙은 숫자인데,
지구를 이루는 원자 수의 약 10%에 해당해.
그리고 실제로 더 나빠져.
125개의 오비탈이 있고 가능한 모든
구성을 저장하려면, 더 많은 메모리가 필요한데
우주의 원자 수보다 더 많은 메모리가 클래식 컴퓨터에 필요해.
그건 슈퍼컴퓨터로는 표현이 불가능한 수준이야.
그래도 양자 컴퓨터에는 희망이 있어.
왜냐하면 양자 컴퓨터는 본질적으로 자연 시뮬레이션에 뛰어나거든.
카페인 분자의 경우, 그건 시스템을
160개의 qubit으로 표현하는 걸 의미해.
그게 훨씬 더 다룰 수 있는 수준처럼 들리지.
더 작은 양자 컴퓨터가 자연을 휴리스틱하게 시뮬레이션할 수 있도록
다양한 양자 알고리즘들이 제안되어 왔어.
그게 바로 변분 양자 고유값 분해기, 즉 VQE야.
VQE는 양자 컴퓨터와
클래식 컴퓨터에서 부분적으로 실행되는 알고리즘이야.
주어진 최적화 문제를 푸는 값을 찾을 수 있게 해줘.
VQE는 양자 근사 최적화 알고리즘처럼
파라미터 변분을 다루는 다른 방법들과 아주 밀접하게 관련되어 있어.
산업이나 연구에서 VQE의 적용 분야를 찾는 건
일종의 예술이지만, 대략적인 가이드라인이 있어.
일반적으로 VQE는 연속 변수를 가진
최적화 문제로 변환될 수 있는 문제들에 적용 가능해.
예를 들어 양자 화학의 많은 부분이 이에 해당해.
화학에서는 매우 자주 바닥 상태에 관심을 갖게 돼.
바닥 상태는 시스템의 가장 낮은 에너지 상태야.
바닥 상태 에너지를 찾기 위해 VQE는
시스템의 다양한 구성에 대한 에너지를 탐색하고
가장 낮은 에너지 구성을 찾아.
높은 수준에서 VQE는 양자 시스템의 설명을 입력받아
가장 낮은 에너지를 찾아.
이걸 시스템의 구성을 변화시켜가며 수행해.
그리고 가장 낮은 에너지를 찾아.
시작할 때 우리는 시스템의 적절한 설명을 입력해야 해.
양자 컴퓨터가 이해할 수 있는 형태로, 그리고 시스템을 설명하는 파라미터 집합을,
이게 최적화될 거야.
알고리즘의 양자 부분이
시스템을 어떤 상태로 준비하는데,
주어진 파라미터 집합으로 설명되는 상태를 준비하고 에너지를 계산해.
반면 클래식 파트는
각 단계에서 그 파라미터들을 최적화하는 역할을 담당해.
이 양자-클래식 과정은 반복되는데
가장 낮은 에너지에 도달할 때까지 계속돼.
이제 내부에서 무슨 일이 일어나고 있는지 좀 더 자세히 살펴보자.
에너지 구성은 보통 Hamiltonian으로 설명되는데,
보통 이건 정말 큰 행렬이야.
대수학에서 행렬의 가장 낮은 고유값을 찾으려면,
즉 시스템의 가장 낮은 에너지에 해당하는 값을 찾으려면,
단순히 특이값 분해를 수행하면 돼.
하지만 우리가 다룰 행렬들은 지수적으로 커서
이걸 대수적으로 푸는 건 지수적으로 어려운 문제야.
이 Hamiltonian은 양자 컴퓨터가
이해할 수 있는 형태로 표현되어야 해.
그러니까 화학 언어에서 양자 컴퓨팅 언어로 번역되는 거야.
세부 사항은 걱정하지 마.
결국 화학에서 흔히 보이는 Hamiltonian을
양자 컴퓨터가 이해할 수 있는 Hamiltonian으로 변환하는 프로그래밍 가능한 방법들이 있어.
그런 다음 이 Hamiltonian을
변분 형태라고 부르는 circuit과 함께 입력해.
변분 형태를 선택하는 건 일종의 예술이야.
다시 말하지만,
이건 시스템의 양자 상태가 어떨지에 대한 우리의 최선의 추측을 나타내.
이 변분 circuit은 파라미터 집합 theta로 파라미터화되어 있고,
이 파라미터들의 초기 선택값도 입력해.
이를 바탕으로, VQE의 양자 파트는:
참조 상태를 준비하는데, 예를 들어 영 상태를 준비하고;
파라미터화된 quantum circuit, 즉 변분 형태를 사용해서 양자
상태를 준비하고, 양자 컴퓨터에서 파라미터의 초기 추측값으로 상태를 준비해. 그리고
Hamiltonian을 통해 평가된 해당 상태의 에너지를 추정해.
이 에너지 추정값은 그런 다음
클래식 최적화기에 전달되고, 최적화기는 새로운 파라미터 집합을 찾아.
파라미터들은 다시 양자 솔버로 돌아가고,
전체 과정이 반복돼.
양자 컴퓨터가 새로운 에너지 추정값을 찾으면,
클래식 최적화기가 새로운 파라미터 집합을 찾는 식으로 계속돼.
솔루션이 수렴할 때까지 이 과정을 반복해.
그건 단계들 사이의 결과 차이가 우리의 필요에 비해
충분히 작아질 때까지를 의미해.
마지막에 알고리즘은 그 최솟값 에너지를 반환해.
좋아, 이건 훌륭해.
그런데 이게 실제로 작동한다는 걸 어떻게 알고,
우리가 찾고 있는 것보다 더 낮은 에너지를 실수로 찾지 않는다는 걸 어떻게 알까?
좋은 질문이야.
우리는 더 낮은 에너지를 추정할 수 없다는 게 밝혀졌어.
이건 우리가 변분 원리라고 부르는 것 덕분이야.
변분 원리는 시스템 에너지의 가장 큰 하한은
항상 그 바닥 상태에 해당하는
시스템의 가장 낮은 에너지라고 말해.
이는 해당 시스템의 다른 어떤 상태에서 평가된 에너지도
항상 가장 낮은 에너지보다 클 거라는 걸 의미해.
따라서 VQE로는 바닥 상태 에너지보다
더 낮은 것을 절대 얻을 수 없어.
하지만 실제로 우리가 찾고 있는 최솟값보다
더 높은 값으로 수렴할 수는 있어.
이건 종종 준안정 솔루션이라고 불리는데,
연구자들이 매일 해결하려고 노력하는 과제야.
VQE는 바닥 상태 에너지를 추정할 수 있는
다른 프로토콜들에 비해 더 얕은 circuit을 사용하기 때문에 유용해.
이게 근미래 양자 하드웨어에 적합하게 만들어줘.
이 영상에서 VQE가 무엇을 할 수 있고 어떻게 구성되는지 살짝 엿봤어.
하지만 이 맥락에서 Qiskit을 탐험해 보길 권해.
비록 우리가 아직 양자 여정의 초기 단계에 있지만,
해결하려는 문제들에 이미 유용하다는 걸 알게 될 수도 있어.
제 이름은 Victoria Lipinska이고, 이건 변분 양자
고유값 분해기 알고리즘에 대한 개요였어.